et c'est votre cerveau c'est son coup de
coeur vous m'avez pg juste syrie je me
préciser c'est que souvent il ya des
caméras cachées on connaît l exercice
mais lui il a une répartie des très
bonnes dans le personnage est un rêve
pour ça c'est un vrai bonheur de aimons
grecs aujourd'hui à ma caméra cachée il
m'a piégé gras guillotin avant tous les
autres avant tous les autres c'est vrai
que j'étais le premier piégée abete a
été adorable en fait je crois que lui
elle m'avait dit tu verras cyril adore
les tarés et ça va pas manquer c'est un
tour ça si la nonna piégé première
partie combat on est sur youtube avec la
chaîne nous cartonne moi j'aime beaucoup
ce que vous faites ici aussi tous et
merci on a envie voilà on a envie de
faire des choses avec vous un délice à
bochum tout ce qui est dit mais moi j'ai
envie de me frotter à la hâte et lâche
mais disons que c'est plus pour l'aspect
thune pour parler vraiment franchement
par contre je ne vois pas être au niveau
de capu des anges ou aux deux motards de
la sécu tu vois c'est un peu c'est un
peux me mettre sur un piédestal c'est un
peu difficile pour moi d'un chômage
on est un peu en mode de fusée en ce
moment et si on nous met là tu vois avec
des gens qui évoluent pas bien
aujourd'hui
les mots fusent et toujours été greffé
ses missions le plus puissant et du paf
oui je vous voyais pas non ça c'est
clair ouais ouais faut pas mettre ma
tête à côté de n'importe qui et tu vois
c'est sur un plan b en fin de match les
dommages seraient déroulés juste pour
qu'on sait on s'en sort pas je finis
juste de mettre quelqu'un tu un showman
mais raconter un peu bruyant tu rigole
tout le temps pour rien tu t'accroches à
un truc pour combler un peu le vide et
laisse passer tu te fais peut-être pas
assez confiance j'ai envie de dire mais
cyril un jour y en a un match des siens
il fait toi confiance quoi t'es bon quoi
tu as du talent bassam a perdu un petit
peu je suis payé comme je suis dans la
rencontre est un peu propre à l'appel et
souleva sur youtube la télé ça paye
c'est plus de pognon je pense je sais
qu'ici vous avez pas mal d'argent tu
veux en parler tout à fait d'être devant
la télé mais ouais par rapport au manque
de classe et où je parlais non je n'ai
pas n'ont jamais d'accord sur ça je vois
le côté sale de l'émission pas c'est pas
un truc qui me dérange ou ré nounou
philatélie populaire je veux pas que moi
je ramène un truc un peu plus français
[Rires]
je sais que toi sur la télé je fais pas
l'unanimité mais tu fais il ya des gens
qui adorent ça
il ya des gens qui te déteste moi sur le
web gêné mais on le voit dans l'est dans
les commentaires je vais rarement des
critiques et 11 et toujours ce mec c'est
la crème du web tu vois
et donc je me dis si moi je m'associe je
peux terminer vraiment mais on est juste
deux secondes je si moi je m'associe à
un moment donné à un type qui fait pas
l'unanimité sur un média qui
sous-performent par rapport à internet
fauqué l'argent et que la place pour
amanda kerdal été super quand papa
selon l'arrêt matthieu delormeau de
leurs maux alors que matthew prend
l'exemple pour le coup ça me fait un peu
grincer des dents parce que de la route
pour moi c'est vraiment la fin ses
niveaux records des chiottes donc tout
ça pour dire poitrine
ce que je te propose c'est que tu
t'appuies sur moi pour l'émission parce
que vous faites ici aussi tout merci
ainsi comme on est un peu en mode de
fusée en ce moment et si on me met là tu
vois avec des gens qui évoluera côté un
peu bruyant tu rigole tout le temps pour
rien et cyril fetwa confiance quoi t'es
bon quoi tu as du talent je veux pas que
moi je ramène un truc un peu plus
français cyril hanouna piéger par le
youtuber tête à claques deuxième partie
offre open numéro un c'est qu'on cohanim
ensemble donc l'intérêt en fait c'est
que du coup ça se cherche un piège et
cherchent un coin tu veux mettre
vraiment je déconne je suis là tous les
jours que justement je ne veux même pas
toujours ici on fait qu anime ensemble
moi avec ma tête de breton toi ta tête
de juif on se passe des vins et tout le
temps ensuite au niveau des chroniqueurs
ça en fera du ménage de leurs maux déjà
voilà dégage donc je le veuille ou non
là tu me prends pas au sérieux mais je
te jure
non non tu aimes pas dans les schémas de
caen c'est important qu'ils perdaient de
dégage ça saute ça saute voit même là ça
fonctionne je trouve quand on interagit
cette fois c'est toi tu m'écoutes je
trouve que tu as de l'ecoute et moi je
et moi j'ai de la probable
attends je termine je devais te fais
parce que je sais que t'as pas beaucoup
de temps et mononc avenue faut qu'on
soit parti non moi je suis partie des
acheteuses des propositions que je vais
faire c'est sûr la gela en fait à deux
marques qui sont forts qu'ils sont c'est
pour nous ces cadeaux et la grande race
rat est en fait tu me tues ferais tu es
pressé pour nous sert à sera je mixe les
deux jeudi à une famille on va vous
offrir une belle maison parce que je
trouvais ça super bon c'est pas nous
c'est cadeau donc les gens viennent ils
voient la maison ils sont contents la
famille et la ville pense est donc
poussé pour nous ces cadeaux ont super
nickel est en fait ils sont dans la
grâce à une caméra cachée il ya un
bulldozer qui défonce la maison c'est
que j'adore mon corps mais après on
rentre tous leurs de décompensation tu
vois des trucs ou une place de cinéma ça
mais bon ben voilà écouter on y va on
monte avec le temps ajouté
ok on le sait durban pour le pognon et
ou du loup alors comment je suis désolé
un vieux première filière on sait en
quoi tu as fait tu passe un coup de fil
bon c'était des caméras cachées
j'adorais comme ceux-là
[Applaudissements]